hey guys today we're going on a hike I'm
pretty excited been a while since I've
been here it's been a while since I've
been fit nebran diversion see snack just
bengay oh no I don't have it snack I'll
share it with you okay well very tiny
but shades on I mean business listings
[Music]
here's the deal today's a really big day
last night Jenna sent me this news
article talking about tarantulas in
Santa Monica
it's currently their mating season and
what a male tarantula finds a female
tarantula he goes up to her web goes
tap-tap-tap
and if she's interested she lets him
into the web they never told us like how
do we know if she's interested like what
does she do it I don't know
it was only a single news article so
I'll have to go and maybe do a little
bit more investigating but right now
we're on the hunt for tarantulas I bet
she lets out a sound like a simple yes
or a simple no will do with their
languages you're gonna keep me to look a
little closer okay fine no cuz I can see
it from here
[Music]
sorry there's a bunny
I saw something nothing back there
you're gonna get tapped what
what do you think John somebody tapping
on this yes it is no it's like an insect
with guys what is this a web somebody's
get busy well then what are they house
an inside I don't know I'm confused what
do you think it is someone's hurting the
population Jed I just jumped like 2
miles back didn't jump I will come in
say I was like aha like a shock like oh
my god I actually thought your antenna
[Music]
doing a little Pokemon hunting here on
the trail I just caught up with ferry it
was quite exciting though my goodness
hope is a 10k it's a gold Dean what's
this is this a tarantula hmm I think he
might be a mango we made out of this
hike Jen we made it alive although
there's still a little bit more woods to
go so there's a very small chance to get
still run into another trench
[Music]
just gotta poo Buddha just wanted to
give you an update if you cared
oh no my clean car dusty with our feet
we made it we survived now we're off to
get a rug I don't want to talk about it
I was like oh god Paul I'm really dusty
do it for the squash always lock your
door seems you're in the car gotta
[Music]